At eight years old, I was
enrolled in dance class.
And by ten, I informed my mother
that I didn't want to go
to school anymore.
I wanted to be likeBilly Elliot
and go to stage school.
She would repeatedly ask me, "Are
you sure this is whatyou want?"
And to me, it was a no-brainer.
At the time, I was just too young
and naive tofeel inadequate.
If Billy Elliot could do it, so could I.
Failing to land the part in thehit sequel
"Nanny McPhee" to "The Big Bang,"
My second audition was for a
show called "Game of Thrones.
I had a hard Bristolian accent and
dark ringsaround my eyes
that were so big they
took up half my face.
I was cheeky.
I was loud.
I was angry.
And for this, I was perfect.